hello everybody hope they are good
today's fomc day and you know what that
means it means volatility but I don't
think it's a type of volatility that you
want to trade in advance because you
don't really know what it's exactly
going to be said how the market is going
to react to it and if it's kind of
gambling so in my opinion if fomc is a 6
PM UTC time then in my opinion this is
what I've always been doing with the
news announcements is to not trade 30
minutes before the news get released and
45 minutes
after the news are released so uh not
only in this case of the fomc not only
the the fomc statement and the
international decision but also the
press conference okay we're gonna go now
into a bit more of detail book today
you're gonna have a 6 pm
the interest rate Division and the organ
also the fomc statement this problem is
not going to bring any volatility
because the market is clearly expecting
that they are going to pause rates so
that's priced in is now when I move the
market but at the exact time also 6 PM
they are going to release the Dot Plot
fomc economic projections okay and that
can give you an idea of what the FED
members are expecting in terms of new
hikes for example or a rate good so I
think that the main question of the day
regarding the Dot Plot is
is the fat still supporting the idea of
a new hike this year okay and we only
have a couple of months left before this
year finishes okay so that's the
question are they projecting a new hike
because that was they were expecting in
the previous Dot Plot
they set two more hikes we only saw one
okay there is one missing so now that
it's kind of like an update of the
economic projection are they still
expecting the same okay one more hike
that's the question all right and that
is where the volatility is Gonna Come
From also of course the press conference
30 minutes after this so on Twitter I'm
Gonna Be Active I'm gonna read the dot
cloth I'm gonna read the FMC statement
I'm gonna give you
um my opinion about it and then at 6 30
is the press conference that's in life
so we're gonna be watching it
um that's also where we could see some
volatility because of course I want to
ask him about the dot product he's just
released 30 minutes before it and also
you know there are things that are they
were asking for example what is going to
happen with inflation if the gasoline
prices keep going up go to the oil chart
it keeps going up it's a ninety dollars
a barrel right now yesterday they went
all the way to 92 93 dollars Okay so
that is going to be a massive problem
for the next CPI report this month the
oil prices have gone up at 10 percent
okay last month it went only less than a
two percent and still CPI
you know went higher than expected so
what's going to happen in the next
inflation report
also of course I want to ask him uh his
opinion regarding uh red Cuts what I'm
going to see rate Goods because well
where I got right now
through what the market is expecting
okay regarding rate goods and I think
the Market's opinion about rate which is
gonna change today uh quite fast in my
opinion I think we might have some
surprises and I think the Market's
opinion is Gonna Change
um right after the press conference so
we're gonna go through that in a minute
let's go the charter we have in front of
us it's the probabilities that the
market gives to the next Target of
interest rates okay so you can see that
in today's meeting they are expecting 99
of the market is expecting that they are
going to hold rates here okay and this
tool CME Group go and Google it it's
free and to be honest it's very accurate
okay or at least in the past uh five or
six FMC meetings I can tell you that
they haven't failed and I've never seen
something as high as 99 so
um I truly believe that I mean they are
going to hold the rates today
that's that's not news you know that's
what the market is expected in everyone
is expected in that it's priced in the
market is not going to move up or down
based on this because this is priced in
Bull at the same time as they announce
the interest rate Edition they are going
to release the Dot Plot and that is
where the volatility is going to come
from so that is where you have to pay
attention to all right and we're going
to take this chart before and after the
fomc meeting because I'm sure I want to
see changing and that can give you an
idea of the market sentiment getting
updated all right so let's continue what
are they expecting in the next meeting
first of November
well they're still expecting that they
are going to post rates okay 70 of the
market believe so this will have a 29
thinking that could be a new hike okay
this is what I think this chart might
change okay
basically the dots plot is going to be
the key because if the Dot Plot is still
projecting one more hike this year then
this is gonna change dramatically maybe
consuming the opposite okay 30 holding
versus seventy percent uh new hike and
even more if your own power comes at the
press conference and says hey what we'll
read about next month's CPI report
because the oil prices have been going
up Non-Stop
so we might we're going to be data
dependent but it's not looking good
and I can't discard a new hike so if
that's the case the Dot Plot announcing
that there is still going to be one more
hard TCR and Jerome power Hokies I'm
worried about the inflation report next
month then I think this is going to
completely flip 30 holding 70 New Height
okay uh that's I think where they were
the first surprise uh could be uh to be
honest and then you can see that in
December the market is also expecting
that they're going to post rates but you
know 35 percent are thinking hey there
might be a new height and 35 percent in
December it's more than 29 in November
so this is telling me that the market is
thinking
or is expecting that the FED is not
going to increase hikes again but if
they did then it would be in December
and not in November and I think this is
what it might change also today all
right let's see the Dot Plot let's see
what happens Bo
volatility
is guaranteed guys there is going to be
a lot of volatility so I recommend you
to not have any positions open before
the data comes out wait at least 30
minutes after the press conference of 45
minutes so if the press conference
starts at half six it probably finish at
seven o'clock UTC time so perhaps wait
until half past seven
or even quarter to wait
okay UTC time uh that's my plan until
then we want to be watching the market
we're going to see why it's unfolding if
there is going to be a false move before
therefore you see that maybe can give
you an idea of why it might actually
happen next okay and then maybe we're
gonna start trading some imbalances that
they're going to be created with that
volatility
with the press conference and the Dot
Plot Okay so
you have to try to understand and choose
when you're going to be an aggressive
Trader and when you're going to be a
conservative Trader and in my opinion
and in my experience
and there's no Financial advice but this
is why it works for me the best when
there are news announcements
I'm conservative I'm not placing any
trades
until the news are released or the data
is released okay then I can trade
imbalances after the dust is settled and
that is my plan for today I'm waiting
until everything gets calmed and then I
might try to trade some imbalances hope
that's clear so now we're going to go
into the Bitcoin chart we'll rather to
make sense of the next potential moves
this is the Bitcoin chart guys daily
time frame so you can see what happened
yesterday and is that we closed the
candle above the daily 50ma now today is
the day that we're gonna know if this is
a deviation or if we're going to test it
a support that's what we are currently
doing and price is going to continue
going higher but for that we have to
wait until the dust settles after fomc
and that's going to give us an idea of
why it's currently going on all right
because as you can see that you know the
daily 50ma it tends to act as a good
resistance support level and you might
be using a different EMA that's fine
choose your levels blue
you can see for example here it's been
tested resistance all the time price
drops this here does a deviation is this
a new deviation okay you can see that it
doesn't get tested our support when it
goes to Tesla support it falls through
it falls off okay so that's the question
are we seeing that today is this scandal
going to hold above the daily 50ma
because if it does then what do you
think we're going to be targeting guys
well of course if this holds if you can
hold the mid frames and the daily 50
Main
also by the way notice how we are
holding a 27 000 exactly psychological
number because it's a round number
before the news are released
this is something very common they like
to hold price before CPI before fomc at
a round number and then I'm gonna move
price up and down because if I tell you
you know price has dropped to 26k
even if it's 26 900
that's a one thousand dollars difference
even if it's not okay it's so
psychological right so that's the first
thing they are holding Above This level
for now until the news are released now
if you don't power
it's not hawkish like it's actually
Davis and maybe the Dot Plot isn't
expecting new hikes
if that happens and they say look this
is the top of the of the hike cycle then
I think we're gonna hold about the
valley 50 Main
and price can continue going higher to
the Rain size 28 300 okay
because this is a range it was a range
and it's still a range
also notice how the liquidations
are in the one month time frame in
hybrid capital in the sun between 28 300
and 20 500 so that is going to be the
next natural Target
if the FMC supports this Theory
however if we see Jerome Powell very
whole keys and serious and concerned and
he says look uh the Double process we're
going to hike if so okay if he says that
and we're probably gonna hike next month
then the market is going to react to
this and what they're going to see we
want to see a selloff all right and
there's going to be a deviation the
daily candle will close below the daily
50ma okay and I might be telling you but
when I go again to the range lows and
today is going to be a lesson for many
of you and I think today is going to be
a good example of sometimes you don't
really need to know where the market is
going next because in this case you know
I'm not Jerome Powell I don't know what
he's going to say so I don't know what
the consequences of his
a speech might be in the Bitcoin price
so I don't really need to know where
price is going to go because it's
impossible to know when you have you
know news announcements and data that
doesn't depend on you but what it
matters is that you know how to react to
it okay so to me it's as simple as that
we hold above the daily 50ma then we go
to the range highs do we lose the daily
50ma and we also lose the mid range then
you know probably we're gonna get maybe
a retest even maybe not and then drop to
the range lows in the next few days okay
it's as simple as that guys sometimes
you don't really need to know why it's
exactly going to happen okay or the
direction but if you know how to react
to why it's going to happen then you're
still going to make money of that
all right so that's what I think uh for
Bitcoin in terms of uh price action uh
in higher time frame if you go to the
four hours time frame let's see if I can
see anything
I mean I can see that we haven't really
retested the 50ma in the forward time
frame support for a while
since literally
one week ago so again it's likely that
today we see price
you know hitting this Zone at least a
support without volatility that we're
gonna see today if the news are about
then we're gonna have full of this okay
are you gonna go to the range loss but
at least I think we'll we'll test this
level okay I just think that even if we
go higher with the volatility of the
moment we're probably gonna test this
level and then go higher okay but this
level should get tested today I think
4.50 May uh that's what I think there's
a chances of literally probabilities I
mean we haven't tested the table for a
week so it's it will be normal to test
it again today okay
that's what I think next
one hour time frame right now above
support
no clear bounces nothing really going on
I mean you can see some candles
to the upside big candles but price not
progressing any further okay
as you can see those three
so that's telling you that there is no
idea and intention to break through this
Zone and I think that's clear because
they're waiting for the news
announcements okay but
um the question is is the market maker
building shorts already was he building
shorts in advance in advance from Monday
uh that's a good question I think okay
because look at these large scandals so
maybe they could give an idea that you
know we actually might go lower
all right so uh keep an eye on that
let's see what happens today but in the
one hour time frame
um that's the little information that we
can extract okay
and then in the 15 minutes time frame
I don't see
any clear scalps I mean you could scalp
just the bounces of the 27 000 Zone
because it's a psychological number that
they want to hold until the news are
released so that's the only thing that I
can see that you want to you know long
this sculptia from 27k to maybe 27 150
or so okay nothing much going on
uh not even worth taking
uh anymore to be honest so if I look at
this chart the only thing that I'm
thinking is
I need to be patient okay I need to wait
until the deuce gets settled today
because you can see that this in this
prosection there is not much really to
trade except this little escapsia
okay
that is the only thing
that you could have trade in terms of a
scalp
um since yesterday okay
now what's really uh going on so I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna wait uh at least 30
minutes after the press conference is
released and then we'll see what they
leave us with if they don't price then
aggressively for example they're gonna
live here some liquidity pools okay and
then if price you know consolidates and
I cannot really start to see here for
example looks to the downside but price
not progressing any further or I see I
don't know an engulfing candle or
something that tells me we're gonna
we're going to reverse and retrace this
liquidity policia then that's when you
can open along okay even if it's a small
long couple
uh this this person will be quite
bigquable even if it's smaller you can
still make money for that okay even if
it's a scalpo I'm telling more as a day
trade
if they leave some big liquidity pools
behind and of course this also applies
to the upside okay
if you start if you see this
okay and then you see
books to the website price not process
any further then you can Target a
reversal towards these liquidity pools
right so uh does I think the type of
trade that I'm trying to look today
just uh retracing imbalances that are
left behind but not positioning myself
in advance before the news are released
because in my opinion that's gambling
you don't know what it's going to be
said okay so be very careful with your
risk management be patient and again
don't try to figure out what the market
is going next just react to it
especially in days like today in other
days yes that's what technical analysis
is about we are trying to understand
what the market is going next
but today it's purely fundamental
analysis and it's you know if he for
example if you don't power mentions the
world session 10 times
the algorithms react to it because they
react to keywords so
how do we know if you're on power is
going to say the word session 10 times
for example we don't know that so no
point trying to guess what is going to
happen but instead better try to react
to the price action okay and then in
terms of the weekly time frame we're
going to go through this again on Friday
on Friday evening but it would be quite
bullish and very important if we manage
to close this weekly Candlestick above
the weekly 50ma because you can see how
this is a strong support and resistance
level check this out okay resistance
sell off support pump
also here resistance okay so now if we
can push above this close the candle
above the weekly 50 May test the support
only when Consolidated here then you
know guys it's very clear we're gonna go
to the Rain size and if we bring the
rain size you can go with high amp break
this highs okay that's when you can be
bullish but do you need the weekly
candle on Sunday to close above the
weekly 50ma okay that's for especially
for position Traders holders swing
Traders okay meow day Traders will be
Traders I think the key time frame today
is going to be what is going to happen
in the daily
time frame okay what is going to happen
with this daily 50ma are we close enough
of it then tomorrow we'll favor higher
prices our inclusion below this then
tomorrow will favor lower prices it's as
simple as that myeongwal for scalpers
are also the Traders go today after the
news are being released go to the one
hour time frame 15 minutes time frame
and try to see if they leave any big
liquidity pools behind
like this I don't carry them where it
goes
and then you can already start to see
here if it's to the website somebody
signs or face to the upside you can see
somebody signs then your goal is to aim
to retrace these liquidity pools after
the news okay and you can go through the
past fomc meetings CPI reports and you
can see how this is usually the case all
right event you might see there's also
something very common a false move
dump consolidate retrace the liquidity
pools
also very common okay or the downside
are there for you force move pump
consolidation retrace
okay
something very common just check the
price action of the previous f1c
meetings and CPI non-farm payrolls that
is usually what happens okay
so I think I don't want to make this
video any longer I think I've been uh
clear with my opinion on my analysis so
I hope that you helped guys thank you so
much for watching
and I'll see you soon